[Musik]
ist das an
wenn das endgame ist wie der name schon
sagt der letzte film im arbeitsalltag
universe das ist die kino adaption von
einem erfolgsrezept das denn leder
marvel comics verleger und editor in
chief sich in den 60ern ausgedacht hat
nämlich dass man teams hat dass man
crossovers hat dass man ein netzwerk von
verizon zwischen damals verschiedenen
heftchen hat die man dann alle kaufen
muss und der geschichte folgen zu können
das kann man auch mit blockbuster kino
film machen sie haben 22 von den dingern
gemacht wir sind bei so 48 stunden
laufzeit ohne die fernsehserien sowas
wie agent of field spielt auch noch mit
rein das blutet alles so ineinander und
es ist natürlich eine komplette
überschwemmung des gehirns was seine vor
und seine nachteile hat wie bei allen
überschwemmungen des gehirns das ende
ist ein teil des weges
also nebenbei orientierungslos durchs
weltall treiben ohne jede chance auf
rettung des industriegleises klingt im
letzten film haben sie die menschen die
da reingegangen sind im grunde beiden
füssen genommen und nach oben gezogen
bis der kopf nach unten war dann
plötzlich war der schurke der held oder
der protagonist das heißt der endete
damit dass ein massenmörder mit finger
gesteckt hat und jetzt endlich zufrieden
ist weil die hälfte aller atmenden
geschöpfe im universum jetzt tot ist was
er von anfang an wollte und jetzt kann
ein rente gehen so kann man film
natürlich enden lassen aber man muss
dann die nächsten film eigentlich damit
anfangen lassen dass das wieder gerade
gerückt wird geht nur nicht so einfach
der erste ansatz ist let's get some of
which capt amerika sagt ok rache reviews
stießen ist kann
machen sie dann bringt aber überhaupt
nichts ist lustig weil sie heißen ja die
rechner also die ruhmreichen rächer
früheren deutschen comic sogar die
avengers dass das aber was anderes ist
dass es gar nicht um menschen geht
sondern dass es darum geht sozusagen
weder die eindeutige entscheidung zu
machen nach einer katastrophe erlebt man
halt weiter noch wir bringen das alles
wieder in ordnung sondern dass man nur
so viel in ordnung bringen kann wie man
auch ein preis dafür zahlt das ist für
ein mega blockbuster gar keine blöde
idee sie reparieren zufügt sie können
allerdings kostet was unter anderem
leuten
tornos hat genau das erreicht was er
wollte
hat
hälfte
lebewesen ausgelöscht das haupt prinzip
von diesem film ist vollkommen
legitimerweise dass es überall bonbons
irgend erdnüsse und sonst was alles für
die leute gibt die in irgend etwas von
diesem universum investiert haben also
sollte die diese figur mögen dieses
setting den handlungsstrang die kriegen
alle was ausbezahlt es ist wirklich
ziemlich genial gegliedert der erste
teil da passiert gar nichts außer
erinnerungen an figuren zeichnungen und
man wird sozusagen noch mal reingeguckt
in der die leute sind und wenn man seine
lieblinge hat dann lebt man sie halt
noch ein bisschen mehr
die zweite stunde ist dann sozusagen das
die achterbahn den berg hoch gezogen
wird und dann rat hat sie halt dermaßen
runter dass man irgendwie hinterher
wirklich erschlagen ist aber relativ
zufrieden die wissen schon wie man so
was macht und der dritte akt ist einfach
eine lawine aus menschen und nicht
menschen die sozusagen ineinander
gekeult werden und zwischen und
durcheinander sozusagen ihre plätze dann
finden und sich neu sortieren müssen als
praktisch wie eine reise nach jerusalem
wo die stühle aber geworfen werden an
kopf ich habe natürlich alle kritiken
gelesen und so viele avengers comics wie
möglich damit ich in die tiefe denken
kann wenn ich das ding hier besprechen
und mir ist aufgefallen der größte
denkfehler der teilweise gemacht wurde
ist zu sagen fans der schurke ist
uninteressant warum weil es von anfang
an irgendwie mighty unbezwingbar und
wird dann doch irgendwie sehen ihr
konntet nicht mit eurem versagen leben
wohin hat euch das gebracht
wieder zu mir er ist nicht uninteressant
er ist deswegen nicht uninteressant weil
er im gegensatz zu fast allen anderen
schurken die in dieser art film
vorkommen nicht eigennützige interessen
verfolgt nicht irgendwie selbstsüchtig
handel seiner tatsächlich gewisser weise
selbst los ist er sagt in dem film
zweimal in erwitte lich war
unvermeidlich das heißt er ist endlich
der verkörperte sachzwang er ist die
tatsache dass vom ceo eines großen
bankenkonsortiums bis runter zur
obdachlosen alle heute sagen ich kann
nichts dafür ich hätte es gerne anders
gehabt aber was willst du machen
er ist sozusagen das klotz geworden was
willst denn machen und sich daran
abzuarbeiten das sorgt schon für eine
sorte drama und für eine sorte tragik
die über die bunten strumpfhosen hinaus
vielleicht sogar den einen oder anderen
gedanken wert wäre den sie sich
zumindest was die art das zu erzählen
angeht auch gemacht haben in form von
einer komplett parade von sozusagen
entscheidungspunkte die man irgendwie
hat wenn man heroisch gegen sowas
kämpfen will
und hier wird dass nämlich ein gewandelt
in die idee einer zeitreise das heißt
die bisherigen filme werden sozusagen
eine revision unterzogen insofern dieser
film sich diese filme alle noch mal
anguckt damit ist die schraube
tatsächlich an punkt gedreht wo man fast
gar nicht mehr anders kann als gucken
wie einfällen selbstkritisch versucht
das hat natürlich ein klebriges und
drogenabhängigen potenzial aber es ist
auch eine form von immersion von
eintauchen
die als eine der wenigen strategien die
das kino in dem bereich hat
beispielsweise mit computerspielen
halbwegs mithalten kann wenn wir das tun
woher wissen wir dann dass es jetzt
anders ausgeht als beim letzten mal im
letzten mal hatte ich mich noch nicht
alle anwesenden kennen sich mit dem
leben als superheld aus und wenn ich das
mal fragen darf wo bist du eigentlich
die ganze zeit gewesen universum gibt es
noch mehr planeten und
bedauerlicherweise hatten die euch nicht
weiterer punkt repräsentation von so
allen möglichen menschen die das gucken
könnten und ja verschieden sind wie wir
heute wissen aus der identitätspolitik
da gibt's dann alle möglichen ethnien
oder sexueller orientierung oder sonst
was
und da gibt es unmut spätestens bei
captain marvel man gesagt hat ja wo mich
zum beispiel dann viele mails erreicht
haben nach den rezensionen ist das jetzt
irgendwie feministisch oder soll das für
die frauen sein müssen die auch noch
vorkommen usw
was dabei vergessen wird wenn die leute
zu tun als würde das den dingern so
aufoktroyiert und das während es
eigentlich unschuldige abenteuer stories
die dann mit diesem moral kam
zugekleistert werden autoritär ist dass
das schon immer so war dass comics als
popkultur schon immer so zu sagen leute
angesprochen haben die so ein bisschen
abseits stehen von so enorm idealbild
und das zum beispiel in den 70er jahren
die black panther geschichten da wäre
denen noch ganz anders
komisch geworden die sich darüber
aufregen dass das zu identitäts
politisch zu emanzipatorisch zu crysis
tisch ist oder so in den 70ern war black
panther ein fucking lehrer unter anderem
schon auf könig von vacando aber er war
dann auch in den vereinigten staaten
lehrer und hat hits die african american
and identity beigebracht also bevor man
irgendwas politisches vermutet hinter
dem was die da machen soll man sich die
quellen noch mal angucken die komik sind
alle schon so
die gefällt mir ich habe neulich hier
ein film über van gogh verrissen und da
war es so der ist nicht so ihre lang
aber alter weiser mann ich dachte
mehrfach ich muss irgendwie aus
biologischen gründen daraus dieses ding
hier ist drei stunden lang ich bin da
locker drin gesessen bis zum ende
obwohl es diesmal sogar nicht mal ein
end credits zähnchen gibt es war ja
immer so dass diese marvel film enden
mit xy kommt zurück in blablabla machen
sie diesmal nicht das heißt sie wollen
auch wirklich ein punkt setzen ich
glaube ja dass der punkten semikolon
wird und dass es weitergeht aber sagen
wir doch so in einer james bond analogie
sean connery ist jetzt erstmal weg aber
wir nicht